l'ho visto stava legge la bibbia vi
presenta subito solo la raffinatissima
il doppio taglio booking ord vi
ricorderete vi metto il film quali
stringe le chiappe natura oppure perché
ti bianchet e ancora ma oggi non voglio
parlare di me ma di un prodotto che mi
ha cambiato la vita
si chiama rotolò stanca di essere grassa
stanca dei signori che esce nei momenti
meno opportuni stanchi di essere
trattata male da un branco di
maschilisti credito
la soluzione fatta apposta per te puoi
saperlo per ingrassare e tombino per
farti dire che sei una grida conservo
per presentarti alle persone quando ai
numeri su date o per crearti un pacco
vero e proprio il teneva il rispetto di
tutti i quali colleghi di opi poi
asciugarci la lingua puoi utilizzarlo
come solvente interno in caso di
necessità
puoi unificarci nelle salve può essere
l'amica che non hai mai avuto ha poi
usarlo contro gli aggressori
come arma di difesa personale pusiano
como sciarpa contro le intemperie
se sembra disposta poi pero il tuo
compagno per sfogarci si dà il benvenuto
alla quarta che hai sempre sognato
se sempre che stava con un bulldog e
rotolò il compagno di un mito adottata
poi l'altra più prorompenti denti più
bianchi rotolò è la risposta
puoi utilizzarlo come alibi per spiare
le persone roma che si avvicendano a no
stanno controllando il cartone interno
tutto a posto ma cara amica non destava
prende per il culo
ecco perché abbiamo deciso di farti
ascoltare le testimonianze di chi ha già
provato voterò io un tempo ero eravamo
pensavo 120 kg di dolori più però grazie
al rotondo sono riuscito ad asciugare
tutti quanti chili di disperazione e in
corso della seduta
beh quando si trattava di darle in giro
ero sempre in prima fila devo essere
sincera comunque non fidatevi di quello
che leggete sulle riviste
diciamo che ingurgitare tutti i liquidi
può essere un mero se lo si fa non è
vero che le proteine fanno bene a furia
di riprendere di assumere
quotidianamente un bel po di protesi mi
ero arrivata a una taglia il 62
io grazie arrotolò utilizzato la
funzione tampax al contrario quindi o
tappato dalla mia gola con con corrotto
e in questo modo sono riuscita a
lasciare i liquidi in eccesso fuori e
invece che dentro ma ti dirò io ho
sempre voluto aver fisico un fisico però
solo valere il fisico però non ci riesco
perché mi piace magna a me piace sfonda
me di cibo e quindi grazie alla funzione
privacy ad essere uno sant'angelo senza
che nessuno sappia chi appartiene quella
pazza
grazie rotolò io vi prego di non fare
commenti i suoi nei capelli perché non
posso tagliarli
e se proprio volete prendervela con
qualcuno prendetevela con lui io adoro
le televendite le trovo geniali fin da
quando è tornato da scuola avevano lo so
12 anni e mi piazzato davanti alla
televisione a vedere le televendite di
miracle blade con core con cher toni o
ancora meglio il migliore giorno e notte
che qualcuno mi dica perché riuscivano
ogni volta a metterci un ingrediente 9
non erano tipo arrivati a metterci
l'interno dei cactus ogni volta al
giorno e notte era più potente di quello
prima che cos'è un iphone che poi per
quello che ho capito le pillole giorno e
notte ti facevano andare in bagno
qualcosa tipo sette volte al giorno ho
reso n'è andato sul loro sito e visto
che esiste una formula ancora più forte
di quella che vedeva da bambino
cosa fa ti stirpe direttamente l'ultimo
tratto dell'intestino dell'origine con
un calzino ti fanno nera nello stomaco
lungi da me né probabilmente attaccare
le persone che creano per le vendite
perché sono sicuro che dietro la
creazione di uno sport di questo tipo
c'è un lavoro pazzesco altrimenti non ti
entrerebbero così tanto in testa ecco io
me li immagino
si allenano nel loro quartiere generale
ma chissà forse non ci siamo capiti che
cosa vuole dalla vita più di ogni altra
cosa nel mondo se non ci ho sentito
parla più forte come carezza tri cel
e cosa state facendo prima che io non lo
so io ci stavo provando a pensare cosa
stavi cercando di fare io voglio
solamente il successo l'eccellenza là
fuori
il mercato delle accarezzati dici tu non
lo sai è un branco di serpi è un pezzo
di sempre la concorrenza è sempre il
club sull'attualità efficienza
professionalità
fammi vedere che cosa si farà e sorridi
cavolo è per morto il cane veramente si
è morto
sì che non lavoro scrive interessa come
si chiamava su elenca qual è la prima
regola di una carezza tritsch e delle
persone non comprano il materasso con
parlano l'idea di sfondare deciso cosa
ti voglio più sexy vanessa qual è la
seconda regola di una carezza trichan
gioco di spalla il risoto il fatto ed ho
vissuto dalle spalle vanessa bene così e
l'ultima regola il più importante
accarezza il materasso come se stesse
accarezzando un capo
mannaggia se lo capisco perché mio nonno
mi dice che i suoi tempi le cose
andavano meglio quindi se li faccia era
roberto baffo che perdeva un polmone per
ogni televendita c'era jill cooper che
riusciva a farsi sette ore di fila su un
tapis roulant a parlare mentre faceva
gli esercizi con le molle sul culo roba
che se l'avessi fatto io a quest'ora mi
sarei molto probabilmente schiacciatelo
c'è la panna marchi alla quale saranno
scoppiate le coronarie per tutte le urla
che cacciava e poi ragazzi c'erano
appelli e le modelle di test mag le
modelle con delle tette di granito e
maschi se non so se avete visto che
avevano più utenti delle donne a volte
vorrei essere nato negli anni 60 si
stava meglio quando si stava peggio